she's debuting a brand new look
[Applause]
Wow okay so this is no you make
headlines over the weekend
it must have been a slow news day for
people to talk about my hat you've a
diet red for what 18 years 18 years and
that's just after I had it colored and
then I went to my hairdresser and he cut
it for me so I loved it I just love the
fact I can call you silver fox man what
did Ozzie say when he saw it he says
that Devil Wears Prada was just so fake
of going and having it dyed and having
it died and I just recite I can't do
this anymore I'm like why am I trying to
do something or be something that I'm
not so just be who you are I like to
change the color of it and be I I get
tired of coloring my hair I have a big
white streak right there and so it's
like it gets tiresome
yeah
[Applause]
I think blondes have more fun for me but
I have a real serious question are you
trying to go after my boyfriend Keanu
Reaves thinking maybe now I stand to
child I remember when I wore the same
color and you said you liked it a lot
yes I do
you look very elegant within a very
stylish and I thought yeah Cheryl yes so
yours is from your scalp mine is on a
wig this color is so on-trend yeah and
so it's very on-trend and very what's
happening now and you look absolutely
beautiful
Jane Fonda Helen Mirren people and I'm
like look how elegant they look and I'm
like okay I'm don't say I'm gonna stop
the surgery just cheese
[Applause]
I know what you doing here so I like
this in the color like this you have to
rock it you have to wear it and not let
it wear you yeah yeah yeah you can do
that she can do it you're rocking it
miss yeah you are
[Music]